I paid 16 dollars for a ticket to see
the first six minutes of The Dark Knight
Rises and IMAX and come to find out it
it came with a free movie so I stuck
around and I watched it Mission
Impossible Ghost Protocol alright so for
me personally I wasn't really excited
for this Mission Impossible movie why
cuz I saw night and day it looked like
it would be fun but it looked like fun
in that Mission Impossible to kind of
fun why are so omission impossible Ghost
Protocol the Kremlin gets bombed and Tom
Cruise and his crew they're blamed for
it Kremlin getting bombed is pretty much
like the Russian 9/11 you didn't want
that to happen so Tom Cruise and
his crew they're out there no support
whatsoever and they got to clear their
names and find whoever did this
or get branded as terrorists get
executed and you know war will happen ya
want that's a bad day hour so Mission
Impossible Ghost Protocol it was good
and it was also great it has some of the
most exciting action sequences I've seen
this side of the summer movie season he
should have been a summer movie why
wasn't it I don't know because there's
probably a lot of like me out
there that didn't think it would be good
turns out it is so you people like me
you are wrong like this scene you saw in
the trailer where he's climbing the
Dubai tower I'd the Dubai tower is the
largest tower in the world he has to
spider-man crawl up the glass and of
course things go wrong things go awry it
turns out to be one of the most exciting
action sequences I've seen like all year
and the good thing about the action in
this movie is it's not just like oh
action sequences ok it's over it's like
oh action sequences ok it's over it's
not over it's still going alright this
was awesome it's great it's a man that
was awesome and now it's a Oates it's
not it's alright keep going
awesome and the characters were cool
they were all relevant it wasn't like
the Tom Cruise show you know it was a
Tom Cruise and crew show like the
teacher chick from precious she's in it
and this just in she should play Jade in
a Mortal Kombat movie I'm just saying
I'm throwing it out there I didn't have
a teacher that looks like her if I did
I'd be like straight A's you bet no I'd
probably failed a class but whatever and
simon Pegg's in it and he's really funny
good thing about simon pegg he has a way
of being funny without it being cheesy I
mean he just has really good comedic
timing and of course Jeremy Renner's in
it there were rumors it was like okay
Jeremy Renner is going to be like some
sort of Tom Cruise replacement but one I
don't think he is and two he was still a
relevant character like not only was his
character cool but there was some
surprising character elements to his
character that I really liked I thought
really worked for this movie all-in-all
exciting action sequence is funny when
it needs to be it all works what you get
is the best Mission Impossible movie
that has
happened yet if you can get past the
point that you know they have this
absurd tech that does not exist but is
really awesome I don't know how they
came up with some of this tech it was
almost like the scriptwriter was like
all right and I want them to walk down a
hallway right in front of a guy like a
guard that's not supposed to see them or
and make that happen in the script you
need absurd tech to do it that doesn't
exist but they did it and it was cool as
hell all-in-all Mission Impossible Ghost
Protocol is awesome tacular and grasped
that I did not expect to give it this
rating especially after I just watched
the first six minutes of The Dark Knight
Rises when you can watch the first six
minutes of what you want to see which is
the Dark Knight Rises and then roll into
a movie that you're like and might be
alright and then have that movie be
awesome tacular that's something this
movie's cool as hell go seed it should
have been a summer movie now we have a
really cool summer movie in winter all
right so the Mission Impossible movies
what's your favorite Mission Impossible
movie comment below let me know even if
it's to no one will hate you for it and
as always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you